Traductor: Denise RQ
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En la historia de la humanidad,
hubo tres pequeñas palabras
que dejaron pensativos a poetas
filósofos en el Ágora,
y oyentes de oráculos:
"¿Quién soy?"
Desde el antiguo aforismo griego
inscrito en el Templo de Apolo,
"Conócete a ti mismo",
hasta el himno de la banda
de rock The Who "¿Quién eres?"
filósofos, psicólogos, académicos,
científicos, artistas,
teólogos y políticos
todos han abordado
el tema de la identidad.
Sus hipótesis son variopintas
y no existe consenso.
Son todas personas
creativas e inteligentes,
¿por qué es tan difícil dar
con la respuesta correcta?
Una traba sin duda reside
en el complejo concepto de la
persistencia de la identidad.
¿Cuál es tu verdadero tú?
¿La persona que eres hoy?
¿La de hace cinco años?
¿La que serás dentro de 50 años?
¿Y cuándo "soy"? ¿Esta semana?
¿Hoy? ¿Ahora? ¿En este segundo?
¿Qué parte de ti es este "yo"?
¿Eres tu cuerpo físico?
¿Tus pensamientos y sentimientos?
¿Tus acciones?
Estas aguas turbias de la lógica
abstracta son difíciles de navegar,
y por eso, a lo mejor conviene usar,
para demostrar su complejidad,
lo que usó el historiador griego
Plutarco: la historia de un barco.
¿Cómo llegas a ser "yo"?
La historia cuenta que Teseo,
el mítico rey fundador de Atenas,
mató sin ayuda de nadie
al malvado Minotauro de Creta,
y luego regresó a su casa en un barco.
Para honrar esta hazaña heroica,
durante los siguiente 1000 años
los atenienses mantuvieron
su barco atracado en el puerto,
y recrearon anualmente su viaje.
Cada vez que algo en el barco
se desgastaba o dañaba,
se sustituía por una pieza
idéntica del mismo material
hasta que, en algún momento, ya no quedó
nada de las piezas originales.
Plutarco hizo hincapié
en que la nave de Teseo
era un ejemplo de la paradoja filosófica
que giraba en torno a la
persistencia de la identidad.
¿Cómo se puede sustituir
cada parte de un todo,
y, sin embargo, este siga
siendo la misma cosa?
Imaginemos que hay dos buques:
la nave que Teseo atracó
en Atenas, el barco A,
y el barco con el que 1000 años más tarde
navegaban los atenienses, la nave B.
Nuestra pregunta es muy simple
y es la siguiente: ¿A es igual a B?
Algunos dirán que durante 1000 años
no hubo más que una nave, la de Teseo
y debido a que los cambios
se realizaron gradualmente,
nunca, en ningún momento
dejó de ser la nave legendaria.
Aunque no tienen absolutamente
ninguna parte en común,
los dos barcos son numéricamente
idénticos, quiere decir que son lo mismo,
de modo que A es igual a B.
Sin embargo, otros podrían argumentar
que Teseo nunca puso un pie en la nave B,
y su presencia en el barco es
una propiedad cualitativa esencial
de la nave de Teseo.
No puede sobrevivir sin él.
Así, aunque los dos barcos
son numéricamente idénticos,
no son cualitativamente idénticos.
Por lo tanto, A no es igual a B.
¿Pero qué sucede cuando
consideramos esta variante?
¿Qué pasa si, ya que cada pieza
de la nave original fue desechada,
alguien recogió todo aquello,
y reconstruyó toda la nave original?
Una vez terminada, sin lugar a dudas
existirían dos naves físicas:
la que estaba atracada en Atenas,
y la que está en el patio
trasero de este individuo.
Cada uno podría reclamar el título
de "La nave de Teseo"
pero solo una podría ser
en realidad la nave genuina.
Así que ¿cuál es la respuesta?
y lo más importante,
¿qué tiene esto que ver contigo?
Al igual que la nave de Teseo,
tú eres un todo, hecho de
partes en constante cambio
su cuerpo físico, la mente, las emociones
sus circunstancias,
e incluso sus peculiaridades,
están siempre cambiando, pero de una
manera increíble y a veces ilógica,
mientra tú permaneces el mismo.
Esta es una de las razones por las que la
pregunta, "¿Quién soy?" es tan compleja.
Y para responderla,
como tantas otras grandes mentes
que lo intentaron antes,
debes estar dispuesto a sumergirte en el
mar sin fondo de la paradoja filosófica
o tal vez podrías responder:
"Soy un héroe legendario que viaja en
un barco poderoso en un viaje épico".
Eso podría funcionar, también.